my name is Jason Silva and I'm a host
and producer with Current TV
our head of programming David Newman who
in very many ways has become a mentor to
us he used to say and I love this the
high road is wide open the low road is
crowded because we were the last
independent cable network in a world of
media conglomerates I think it freed us
to to seek exceptionality in a way that
others perhaps governed by the bottom
line couldn't do it you know we could
start from scratch and therefore that
allowed for a space of elevating the
conversation I also think people were
hungry for that I think reality
television has has fried some people's
brains and I think people were ready for
something of more significance for a
real conversation about this global
enterprise is very progressive people
that really are socially conscientious
about things that matter to them you get
a lot of green eco sort of renewable
energy type of content people exploring
these things a lot of stuff on politics
unique perspectives on politics around
the world a lot of stuff from the Middle
East I remember a piece of content for
example that you know one of the very
first piece of contents that ever aired
on current was this piece about
underground party scene in Tehran in
Iran where this filmmaker Yasmin
Vesuvian showcased how kids have to
party in secret hiding from the
religious police because it's very much
a theocracy so it's kind of like the
religious values are enforced onto
people so you can't drink you can't
pardon you can't say has to be done in
hiding and so here's something you don't
really see you hear about in CNN where
you're talking about all these crazy you
know nuclear the possibility of nuclear
proliferation there and isn't that but
here you're seeing like regular kids
just trying to have a good time and if
being forced to do it underground I
think it kind of it reaches people in
that demographic here in the states I
think also seeing the election of Obama
I think you've seen a generation of
people that are empowered and feel
empowered and want to have a say in the
world and I think that that has risen up
firm from the ashes of crap that has
been a lot of television recently
we try to cover the world of young
adults in their voice and from their
point of view we try to do so in a bold
in a reverent fashion we don't dumb
things down for our audience in fact
even the stuff that is hilarious on the
network is highly intelligent we have an
animated series called super news which
have mocks pop culture in a brilliant
fashion we have a show that's it's a
sort of a comic indictment of the media
I'm called info mania which also is very
clever I mean I think that you can you
can appeal to mass consciousness and pop
culture I mean it doesn't always have to
be highbrow subject matter but it can be
tackled even if it's lowbrow subject
matter or mainstream subject matter
we've did an hour a secular our
exploration of religion and spirituality
you know if you saw the recent cover of
Newsweek is at the end of Christian
America as far as its influence on
politics in many ways which i think is a
very good thing I think religion has no
place in politics and so we did an
exploration of the way that some people
in different religious communities are
trying to reach out to the larger larger
groups that are no longer identifying
themselves with any religion me and max
always like to have a spirited
intellectual discussion if possible and
but do so in a way that it's fun and
natural and real and is the same that we
would be having if we were having a
cocktail at the bar this is just like
who we are
features such as on-demand the features
that you're having on television will
continue to become more complex and
sophisticated in and you'll probably
have I guess internet browsing on your
television and you'll have increased
high definition on demand video on the
computer probably becoming
interchangeable you know I suspect that
communication tools will increasingly
become more portable so more and more of
our like typical communication computer
communication will happen unlike devices
such as the blackberry or the iPhone and
so more and more of our content
consumption will become more more
interactive but in a medium that looks
kind of like a big-screen computer
monitor / TV
I would say one of the best pieces of
advice that I've ever gotten is has been
echoed by two great thinkers my mother
Linda Michigan and Joseph Campbell
Joseph Campbell said follow your bliss I
couldn't agree more with that my mom
always said just do what you love you
know don't worry about anything else
don't worry about money don't worry
about anything just be kind to everyone
and do what you love as long as you're
not hurting anybody else I mean kind to
people and you're doing what you love
only good things can come of it
other good advice is uh is people who
claim to have absolute irrefutable faith
in something without any evidence I
would not trust completely yeah I just
it I'm uh I'm uh I relate a lot of
people like Carl Sagan I recently read
one of his books that was based on a
speech that he gave in a in a divinity
school he's interesting because Carl
Sagan was 100% a scientist but he was
very spiritual I mean and he said the
universe gives us plenty to be spiritual
about we don't need to adopt any form of
dogma look at the evidence and to be
willing to question your own truths and
to be willing to scrutinize things that
you hold dearly because that way that
transparency that self-awareness will
protect you from ever becoming somebody
that whose beliefs somehow make them
have myopic vision about what could be
so remain open and be willing to be
transformed by new information
you